can't be any weirder than freaking the
light heavyweight division
with uh Jamal Hill going on his YouTube
channel if you haven't watched it it's a
good watch it's a tough watch it's
authentic you can see it's the first
time he kind of comes to terms with him
rupturing his Achilles tending while
playing a UFC basketball Celebrity Game
and he realizes he's out for a hot
second I I know the divisions like in
this weird turmoil but it's pretty
exciting because you got a bunch of
killers Yuri's Yuri versus Alex such a
fun fight
um we just need Alex to get past yawn
it's his Duff's match up besides uh
Margaret Madoff that there is Monument I
mean by far the toughest match-up form
if you just get over that we're going
Sizzler that division is gonna be fun
because Yuri Alex is fun Johnny Walker
Alex is fun rack cake Alex is fun